voici lance deux régions l'udf qui
compte 5 président élu grâce aux voix du
front national est réuni
la direction de leur part qui devrait
leur demander de démissionner sinon ils
seront exclus pour les français le
cancer reste la maladie la plus redoutée
malgré les trop vrai qui permettent de
soigner plusieurs types de cancers 1%
tout juste des français pensent que l'on
peut réellement guérir un anglais à
paris tony blair est venu dire en
français aux députés qu'il n'y avait
plus de politiques de droite ou de
gauche mais une bonne ou une mauvaise
politique économique
le gouvernement examine demain un projet
de loi contre l'exclusion un phénomène
qui concerne l'emploi le logement mais
aussi la santé
c'est notre enquête de ce soir le guide
du routard fête ses 25 ans de katmandou
à la banlieue parisienne il veut
permettre à tous de goûter aux joies des
voyages
madame monsieur bonsoir après les
élections régionales qui ont provoqué le
tangage de la droite rpr udf après la
mise au point hier soir du président de
la république
cet après midi les responsables
nationaux de l'udf qui sont les
principaux concernés par les alliances
avec le front national sont réunis cinq
membres de l'udf ont été élus à des
présidences de région avec les voix du
front national
la majorité des dirigeants du df demande
leur démission ou leur exclusion mais
cette ligne ne fait pas l'unanimité
j'évite imbert raimu procès c'est le
déjeuner de la conciliation
les ténors de l'udf se retrouve dans un
restaurant parisien ce midi françois
léotard françois bayrou alain madelin
il s'agit de trouver en petit comité la
formule qui conviendra ce soir au plus
grand nombre et surtout éviter
l'éclatement de l'udf
ce qui nous unit est plus important que
ce qui nous sépare
il ya des choix à faire et nous allons
devoir les faire et ses choix sont
apparemment difficile à effectuer
officiellement une ligne se dessine il
s'agit d'une demande de démission pure
et simple adressé aux cinq présidents de
région udf et du grâce aux voix du fn
mais lorsque le bureau politique débute
en fin d'après midi certains points de
vue sont encore diamétralement opposées
ne crois pas qu'on puisse réunir
durablement pour la même table des
hommes et des femmes pour les uns
pensent qu' il faut traiter avec front
national et dans les autres récuser
réprouvent ses choix
c'est pas en excluant ces personnalités
là qu'on arrivera à repartir sur des
bases qui permettent de redonner
confiance aux électeurs de redonner
confiance à la démocratie un temps lourd
plane sur l'idf jean françois deniau qui
en était l'un des fondateurs annonce
spectaculairement qu'il quitte le
mouvement et qui est aussi la salle de
réunion la question de la présidence de
l'udf sont également être là
françois les rues d'art va devoir
s'expliquer françois bayrou lui prend
déjà date en pensant à son propre à
l'époque je vais plaider que nous
pensions à la construction d'une
formation politique nouvelle il soit
clairement une formation connue de
nouvelles au centre et au centre droit
qui acceptent ces valeurs on ne sait pas
si la question des présidents de région
élu grâce à l'extrême droite sera réglée
ce soir n'a de prise à lui des fl est
loin de l'air et en direct avec nous du
siège de l'udf j'habite un berger flat
réunion n'est toujours pas terminée
cette réunion du bureau politique de
l'udf pourrait durer une bonne partie de
la soirée cela prend du temps car on
cherche une formule qui convienne à tout
le monde puisqu'on l'a vu il ya des
divergences sur cette question de
demande de démission des présidents de
région idf qui ont été élu grâce aux
voix du front national alors on irait
peut-être vers un texte qui prendra en
compte en quelque sorte les aspirations
de ses électeurs de droite qui sont
favorables aux alliances avec le fn tout
en fait réside dans la formulation en
tout cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'aucun des cinq présidents concernés
de région en étaient présents ce soir il
n'y allait notamment pas charles millon
qui est un membre important de ce bureau
politique
on sait aussi que charles baur par
exemple en picardie a déjà annoncé qu'il
n'avait pas l'intention de démissionner
et un sondage bva pour paris match
indique que 61% des sympathisants idf ne
sont pas favorables à un accord avec le
front national
trente cinq pour cent pensent le
contraire pour les sympathisants rpr 55
% sont contre un accord avec le front
national
43% n'y sont pas opposés témoignages des
difficultés des nouveaux présidents de
région élu grâce aux voix du front
national cet après midi au conseil
régional de picardie le président
charles baur à une grave altercation
avec le représentant communiste gérard
lalot cet après midi au conseil général
de picardie charles baur et ne devait
pas rester à la tête une région
aujourd'hui marquée du sceau de la
famille et de la collaboration
je les jeux même temps donc pas libre il
accepter les diktats du parti communiste
pas m
vous le voyez donc les cinq présidents
de droite des conseils régionaux élu
grâce aux voix du front national sont
donc soumis à d'énormes pressions
certains les ignore comme jacques blanc
à toulouse charles baur convient de voir
en picardie un autre au moins réfléchi
charles millon qui déclare ce soir
vouloir recueillir l'avis de l'ancien
président de la république valéry
giscard d'estaing
après s'être entretenu ce matin avec
raymond barre didier guyot jean claude
marin difficile en fait pour charles
millon d'être serein officiellement y
préside
mais impossible pour lui de trouver
désormais une majorité la gauche
plurielle leur excellent mais surtout
ses propres troupes font défaut
et puis il ya le front national qui
vendredi donner ses voix et qui
aujourd'hui demandent des excuses
il ya une voie ouverte entre la
démission de monsieur millions il ya une
autre possibilité qui d'ailleurs est
extrêmement à la mode c'est la
repentance sur 61 conseillers régionaux
issus de la droite traditionnelle une
vingtaine ne serait plus d'accord avec
charles millon le rang des fidèles
s'éclaircit peuple c'est pourquoi tout
l'après midi ces derniers amis ont
multiplié les suspensions de séance pour
tenter de sortir de cette impasse
bernard pons est arrivé ici tout à
l'heure il est venu écouter les élus et
repères quant à charles millon il
rencontrera valéry giscard d'estaing
jeudi prochain visiblement le président
de la région cherchent une issue
c'est le titanic aujourd'hui au colmate
une loi domicile et l'autre qui s'ouvre
la question aujourd'hui c'est à quelle
heure cool le titanic dans les rues de
lyon trois à cinq mille manifestants se
sont réunis tout à leur place bel des
manifestants qui dénoncent l'attitude de
charles millon voudra quant à jean
pierre soisson élu lui grâce aussi aux
oies du front national ils n'excluent
pas désormais la possibilité de
démissionner de la présidence de la
région bourgogne si celle ci se révèle
ingérable décision qu'il prendra at-il
dit de manière collective avec ses
colistiers retour en arrière c'était
hier soir très tard finalement le
spécialiste et jean production a été élu
président de la région ile de france 3e
tour l'ancien collaborateur de michel
rocard a bénéficié de l'abstention des
élus de la droite rpr udf qui n'ont pas
lu ainsi à refuser les voix du front
national qui risquaient de se porter sur
leur candidat après l'intervention du
président de la république hier soir qui
partant de la crise politique actuelle a
proposé une rénovation de la vie
politique en france notamment du système
électoral
le premier ministre lionel jospin qui ne
voulait pas être en reste en quelque
sorte a aujourd'hui annoncé à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il allait très
rapidement proposer des solutions
une fois retombé tout de même at-il dit
l'émotion suscitée par ces dernières
élections guilaine chenu jean-marc
source
confidences de couloir commentaires des
déclarations un jour de rentrée
parlementaire sous le choc des élections
régionales
aujourd'hui c'est l'assemblée qui est
sous tension et qui se laisse aller au
chu
chers collègues le spectacle donné ces
derniers jours est assez lamentable pour
que ce ne soit pas la même chose du sud
sur les bancs du gouvernement lionel
jospin se préparent à intervenir jacques
chirac annoncé hier une rénovation de la
vie politique
le premier ministre veut prendre sa
place dans le débat l'ironie il allait
ça c'est elle et lui aussi loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats une autre sur la
réforme de la justice
lionel jospin décline d'action de son
gouvernement et promettent un changement
de scrutin
sans oublier de commenter les résultats
des élections je pense que ce choc qui
s'est produit au lendemain des élections
régionales ne doit pas les uns et les
autres nous tétaniser mais au contraire
nous mettre en mouvement pour opérer de
nouveaux progrès applaudissements sur
les bancs de la gauche à droite on se
dit prête à suivre jacques chirac mais
beaucoup moins lionel jospin sur ce
thème des réformes institutionnelles
chacun retrouve son camp il ya
naturellement les répondra
fonctionnelles elles sont essentielles
mais il y a les réformes sociales
les propos du premier ministre sont une
ouverture il faut pour approfondir il
s'est contenté de phrase qu'on l'a
entendu dix fois à l'assemblée nationale
fera bientôt une nouvelle déclaration de
politique générale à l'assemblée
c'est désormais une course de vitesse
qui s'engage entre le président et le
premier ministre sur la rénovation de la
vie politique
bon venir à la réunion du bureau de
l'udf françois léotard est sorti de la
réunion monsieur léotard bonsoir bonsoir
vient alors des décisions ont-elles été
prises ce soir quant aux cinq membres du
bf qui ont accepté des présidences de
région grâce aux voix du front national
oui nous avons examiné bien sûr la
situation politique issue des élections
régionales et nous avons pris la
décision
de demander au président de région qui
se sont mis dans cette situation et dans
cette situation d'impuissance de
démissionner et s'il ne le faisait pas
bien entendu à ce moment là puisqu'ils
sont en contradiction avec les décisions
et orientations prises par l'ensemble du
bureau politique de l'udf il ya déjà
quelques temps
s'il ne le faisait pas bien entendu une
des procédures à ce moment-là
d'exclusion serait engagée il ya cette
chose est claire on a dit aussi que à
l'occasion de ce bureau des hommes comme
monsieur alain madelin qui dans un
premier temps avait félicité les
nouveaux élus n'étaient pas forcément
d'accord avec vous tout le monde était
d'accord c'était l'unanimité ce soir ou
si la crise avait je ne connais pas seul
bureau politique de partis en france qui
recueille l'unanimité enfin en tout cas
c'est très rare dont nous avons eu un
débat c'est vrai mais il ya une très
large majorité qui s'est exprimée dans
le sens que je viens de vous indiquer
c'est à la fois une question comment
dire de principe nous avions voté avant
et nous faisons qu'est ce que nous
avions voté les électeurs de ces
présidents n'ont pas été informés avant
l'élection de cette alliance de fait et
enfin les valeurs que nous essayons de
défendre qui sont celles de l'humanisme
libéral du personnalisme de l'engagement
européen ne sont pas par définition les
mêmes que celles du front national
je doute que les projets régionaux qui
avait été présenté par ces présidents
étaient profondément différents de ceux
du front national
donc il ne faut pas qu'ils aient
tromperie si on veut essayer de faire en
sorte que la vie démocratique des
français s'améliore il ne faut pas agir
de cette manière devant les électeurs ou
plutôt après leurs consultations et dans
les couloirs françois le père ma
question était plus simple
monsieur madelin at il persisté dans sa
position de soutien au président élu y
at il une annie il n'y a pas unanimité
il est à discussion est ce qu'est ce
qu'on risque de déboucher sur une crise
au sein de l'udf je m'efforcerai bien
sûr de les citer mais sur ce sujet comme
sur un certain nombre d'autres mais sur
ce sujet capital qui concerne la
conscience de chacun d'entre nous s'il
doit y avoir des différences qui
continuent à apparaître et bien à ce
moment là il y aura des recompositions
qui se feront c'est évident nous n'avons
pas à transiger sur des questions de
conscience je ne veux pas je ne peux pas
accepter pour moi même avoir combattu
une certaine forme d'intolérance en
région provence alpes côte d'azur être
aujourd'hui
désavoué alors que je n'ai fait que
répondre à ce que nous avions ensemble
décidé alors je repose ma question
autrement on va y avoir des claquements
de portes que la sortie de la réunion ce
soir ou pas aujourd'hui il se peut que
dans les jours qui viennent nous ayons
encore des discussions sur ce sujet moi
je plaiderai pour une ds pacifié
homogène c'est à dire ayant à défendre
les mêmes valeurs et 13 attentif à
l'efficacité de son message dernière jeu
dernière chose est ce que quelqu'un a
remis en cause votre statut de président
de l'udf en personne personne mais j'ai
bien indiqué qu'il n'était pas possible
à quelques présidents que ce soit de
continuer à assurer cette fonction dans
la confusion
donc j'ai besoin de clarté à l'intérieur
du doj comme j'imagine
d'autres en ont besoin dans d'autres
formations et s'il ne se tartiner
n'existait pas bien j'en tirerai les
conséquences vous pourriez
éventuellement démissionner à ce moment
là s'il n'y avait pas cette clarté de la
communauté des valeurs et je crois que
ce soir nous l'avons obtenu j'espère
qu'on pourra aller un peu plus loin dans
les jours qui viennent
merci beaucoup monsieur d'état le
tribunal administratif de marseille
vient de demander l'annulation de la
location municipal de naissance liés à
la préférence nationale qui avait été
décidé par la municipalité front
national de vitrolles décision pris cet
après midi et puis la cour d'appel de
grenoble vient de confirmer la
dissolution du théâtre national de
château ballon qui avait fait l'objet
d'un conflit avec la municipalité front
national de toulon aussitôt après cette
annonce madame trautmann ministre de la
culture elle déclaré qu'elle allait
créer la nouveau centre de création
nationale culturelle on sait les progrès
effectués dans la lutte contre les
différentes formes de cancer et pourtant
selon un sondage ipsos pour 43% des
français le mot cancer évoque encore une
maladie incurable et la mort et seul 1 %
pensent que l'on peut vraiment en guérir
en fait les français sont partagés entre
l'espoir et la peur face à un fléau qui
reste de loin le plus redouté françoise
valais philippe chasselas
le cancer fait peur et denise en sait
quelque chose
atteinte d'un cancer du sein elle est
opérée et suit des traitements lourds
cette tête il ya 24 ans pour moi ça a
été très difficile
c'était une maladie qu'il sait faire
peur et surtout c'était une maladie dont
on avait dont on ne parlait pas c'était
indécent d'en parler depuis denise a
décidé de consacrer une partie de son
temps aux personnes malades du cancer
une preuve de vie car contrairement aux
idées reçues le cancer n'est pas une
maladie incurable
cette idée avait fait maintenant je suis
persuadé du contraire je persuadé du
contraire avec grâce et d'équipements
dicale mais aussi grâce à des
organisations qui viennent nous soutenir
et qui nous apportent leur aide et les
témoignages sont nombre de malades qui
après un traitement ou retrouver une vie
normale
pourtant 1% des français seulement
croient à la guérison
allez un problème de communication qui
est important parce que ils viennent
dire que ce n'est pas vrai vous avez des
types de cancer qui guérissent
pratiquement toujours vous avez d'autres
types de cancers qui vont être plus
grave
mais pensez que c'est simplement un pour
cent des corsaires qu'il guérisse
c'est pas du tout la réalité on guérit
par exemple 70% de tous les cancers chez
l'enfant 90% de ceux de la peau 95% les
cancers des testicules et dans la
plupart des cas difficiles les taux de
survie ont largement augmenté
reste la prévention les français disent
pouvoir agir pour limiter les risques
c'est vrai qu'ils arrêtaient de fumer le
nombre de cancers du poumon mais serait
de 90% au procès de maurice papon à
bordeaux cette fois ci le dernier acte
ait véritablement commencée le défenseur
principal de l'accusé m jean marc varaut
a entamé une plaidoirie de trois jours
visant à demander l'acquittement de
l'ancien secrétaire général de la
préfecture de la gironde
estimant que celui ci ne doit pas être
le bouc émissaire du régime de vichy
dominique verdeilhan patrick des chemins
coeur
mètres 25e du temps qui passe cinquante
ans après dit il c'est le dernier procès
de l'épuration qui se déroule à bordeaux
cette période de l'occupation l'avocat
estime bien la connaître
j'ai écrit quatre livres mais je
m'aperçois l'issue de ces six mois que
je ne savais rien mon coeur est du côté
des parties civiles avance-t-il
même à raison leur dis vous n'auriez pas
dû faire ce procès voilà dix ans je
participe à la dénonciation de l'os cost
et aux souvenirs indicible et
inexplicable du crime contre l'humanité
je suis aujourd'hui partie civile contre
le crime et je défends maurice papon
pour éviter la banalisation de secret
homme de droit homme de lettres
académiciens m 20 euros donne sa version
sur riche en huile chi dit il a mené une
politique antisémite d'exclusion mais
pas d'extermination l'initiative était
toujours allemande une position de la
défense qui ne sied pas aux parties
civiles qui parle de révisionnisme dire
que la politique d'exclusion n'était pas
une politique raciste
c'était quoi alors c'était quel type de
politique alors effectivement on sait
contenu pendant six mois mais maintenant
on a droit aux discours révisionniste ça
va durer pendant trois jours entre
courtoisie et grandiloquence jean marc
varaut s'adresse aux jurés peuple de
france lors dit-il vous acquitterez
maurice papon qui ne saurait être le
bouc émissaire du régime de vichy
mais entre habilité et provocations il
ne cite que très rarement le nom de
maurice papon ce procès dépasse l'accusé
comme jamais dit-il sauf peut-être le
capitaine dreyfus l'acquittement et la
comparaison avec le capitaine dreyfus
sont deux mots il passe très mal ce soir
sur le banc des victimes
bernard tapie à nouveau devant la
justice en appel de sa condamnation à
trois ans de prison dont 18 mois avec
sursis dans le cadre de l' affaire des
comptes de l'om la cour d'appel doit
décider si cette peine doit être réduite
ou augmenter bernard tapie a choisi
cette fois le silence pas de
déclarations ses avocats sont également
près 10
dans la sphère de la petite ludivine
assassinés au cours d'un séjour à la
montagne la semaine dernière par un
employé du centre où elle séjournait les
enquêteurs ont décidé de procéder à un
test adn sur le coupable présumé qui va
être comparée aux traces retrouvées sur
les lieux d'un autre meurtre celui de la
petite caroline dickinson à pleine
fougères en 1996 et dont l'assassin
reste toujours introuvable
les agriculteurs en colère contre le
projet de réforme de la politique
agricole commune qui pour cause le
concurrence internationale prévoit de
réduire les aides collectif pour les
remplacer par des aides directes pour
revu à la baisse
la fnsea a demandé à ses troupes de
manifester un peu partout en france et
notamment de manière symbolique vous le
voyez dans la commune du premier
ministre cintegabelle
rappelons que dans les tacles des choses
le gouvernement français n'acceptent pas
cette réforme de bruxelles
demain le conseil des ministres doit
examiner le projet de loi du
gouvernement contre l'exclusion sociale
principalement centrée sur les problèmes
de logement et d'emploi mais exclusion
la mise en marche concerne également la
santé comme en témoigne cette enquête
menée à saint denis en banlieue
parisienne auprès d'un médecin de
quartier dont les patients n'ont plus
les moyens de se faire soigner
jean marie n'est là jacques gérault
premier patient de la journée david est
venu se confier aux médecins de famille
officiellement guérie d'un accident du
travail
il souffre encore les députés
reconnaissent à saré apparaît donc c'est
pas du tout guérir
bon bah écoute il va falloir qu'on fasse
quelques examens quand même parce que
cette jambe à l'époque d'affaires en
forme coût prévisible des examens où ils
feront au problème
le jeune homme qui n'a pas effectué
toutes les démarches nécessaires n'est
plus en règle avec la sécurité sociale
il devra avancer les frais pas son
contrat de qualification je gagne 3200
francs par mois mais elle bute sur une
paire qu'en ce moment et les examens
vous pouvez avancer plusieurs centaines
de fois ou pas à vrai dire pas vraiment
parce que si je perds presse à moi de
gérer pour ma femme et moi et de façon
assez serré oui voilà donc je vais
appeler la sécurité sociale et
on va essayer de régler ce problème il
va se régler les problèmes en inquiète
pas c'est pas c'est simplement s'il n'y
a pas un moment donné le groupe à pied
au bon moment tout le système n'est plus
n'est plus adéquat méconnaissance de la
réglementation ignorance des procédures
une partie de la clientèle du cabinet
est exclue du système de soins certains
ont baissé les bras
ils sont devenus étrangers à leurs
droits ça demande une connaissance une
force physique des heures d'attentes va
tout c'est que tous ces problèmes là qui
demandent en fait d'être en bonne santé
et par définition les gens sont en
mauvaise santé pour faire ses démarches
et on voit bien que le système coin cela
leur donne ans ne fait pas tout ici pour
soigner il faut également tenir compte
des conditions de vie elles peuvent
compromettre par les chances de guérison
sans vraiment par son souffle et autant
c'est important je tends nuit pour
vérifier que tu prennes bien des
médicaments pour moi c'est la même chose
de vérifier comment tu manges c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que tu m'expliques comment
tu manges avec mille francs à deux
bombes à 1 c'est au bout du quinzième
jour ou du 20ème jour il ya plus rien
quoi pour manger pratiquement cédé
boîtes de conserve ses temps en temps à
sandwich c'est dur donc il ya des jours
du match pas du tout hu a pratiquement
pas dire ça un examen médical de puces
la routine de docteur mineurs le cercle
seuil nécessaire pour améliorer leur
état général de son patient alors c'est
lui qui va parlementer avec
l'administration
il a le droit à son allocation d'adulte
handicapé et patience
armand demandant s'il ya un refus de la
cave et il est pas légitime il faut
s'opposer à ça ils n'ont pas le droit de
refuser un précieux sinon il perd
beaucoup là quelques immeubles plus loin
visites à domicile
le problème que nous avons ici c'est
bien essentiel des problèmes sociaux
liés à l'accès aux soins entre autres
plus le problème du chômage
là tout ce qui tourne autour du mal être
du mal vivre c'est ça le problème c'est
pas des maladies
particulier retour au cabinet bilan de
la journée 26 consultation la moitié des
malades n'ont pas d'argent pour le pays
cela viendra plus tard quand ils
pourront la confiance est réciproque
ici avec le médecin on reste encore en
famille solidaire malgré les
désillusions je me suis installé ici je
pensais pouvoir soigner des gens et je
fais en fait même les sens et dans mon
travail c'est dans le voyez des puits de
secours pour votre légende ce nom
une première cette après midi à
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre anglais tony blair est venue en
france s exprimer devant les députés
contrairement à ce qui se dit encore en
france pour tony blair il n'y a plus de
politique économique et sociale de
gauche ou de droite mais simplement une
bonne ou une mauvaise politique jean
marc il use philippe naudy je vais donc
vous parler
on pensait alors que rage unanimité
bonne humeur retrouver cet après midi au
palais bourbon pour applaudir un premier
ministre socialiste mais britannique
francophones mais iconoclaste et même ex
garçons de café à paris voilà vingt ans
leçon chose mais je me suis bien dans
l'époque l'abbé dans ce bar un pot
commun et on m'a dit strictement qu'il
fallait y mettre
tu les pouvoirs au bout de deux mois
j'ai découvert que j'étais la seule à la
faire
c'était ma première leçon de socialisme
appliquée applaudissements plus nourris
à droite et leçon numéro deux chapitres
est connue la gestion de l'économie
n'est ni de gauche ni de droite
les bonnes ou mauvaises la cie re succès
à droite on sent comme de la réserve
chez lionel jospin mais le camarade tony
égalise rapidement le score et s est
bien gérée par la gauche aujourd'hui
tout ça me paraît à la fois moderne
profondément socialiste - si j'étais
anglais je serai au parti travailliste
mais je ne suis pas sûr que si monsieur
blair était français ils seraient
socialiste j'ai observé que tony blair
avait été beaucoup plus applaudis par la
droite que par la gauche
décidément à chacun son tony blair et
parmi les soucis de tony blair cette
information diffusée en grande-bretagne
qui avait l'avait obligé à placer la
police en état d' alerte les irakiens
auraient tenté d'introduire dans le pays
le bacille du charbon l'anthrax
dissimulés dans des flacons de parfum ou
d'alcool une tentative en fait de guerre
bactériologique que l'irak dénonce ce
soir comme une information sans fondre
la commission d'information
parlementaire chargée de faire la
lumière sur le comportement de la france
dans les événements qui ont amené au
génocide du rwanda en 1994 a commencé à
de siéger elle aura peut-être à entendre
des témoignages très durs sur l'attitude
des autorités françaises au début des
événements au moment où la minorité
tutsie cherchait à être défendu
reportage eric monier franzen les
français qui pouvait faire quelque chose
pour moi m'ont abandonné au panda ils
m'ont abandonné à la mort alors je suis
travail est beau alors que je
travaillais pour eux donc je me
considérais comme un
un individu qui était dit qu'ils avaient
autant de droits de l'homme que et
malgré ça ils m'ont laissé parce que
tout simplement j'étais tout et au
rwanda en avril 1994 personnes à la
coopération française où elle
travaillait n'ignorait keaven était
toute personne ne pouvait ignorer non
plus qu en refusant de l'évacuer avec
les ressortissants français ont la
désignait à une mort quasi certaine de
sa famille ne lui reste que quelques
folies dans ses gènes si j'ai perdu
toute la totalité de ma famille tous mes
amis et et je crois pas qu'il faut qu il
faut pas qu'ils soient morts pour rien
quoi il faut quand il faut que la
justice soit le se soit rendu au rang
des pierres devenu depuis son mari était
coopérants français il a refusé lui de
l'abandonner
ensemble ils ont réussi à s'enfuir mais
jamais ils n'oublieront le mépris de
certains membres de l'administration
française on m'a dit que c'est pas ça ne
concernait pas c'est pas une histoire de
français c'est pas une histoire de blanc
c'est une histoire entre les rwandais
donc une guerre tribale une guerre
interethnique et qu il faudrait que
j'assume ma guerre qui était une barbare
et pour comment vous expliquer cette la
lâcheté la paire d'as comptabilité le
l'implication de la france c'est
imaginable
l'implication de la france des pierres à
partir de 1990 et jusqu'au génocide
l'armée française est bien présent au
rwanda coopération militaire voulue par
les gouvernements français de gauche
puis de droite
début avril 94 la france évacue ses
ressortissants et les dignitaires du
régime
elle embarque les bourreaux qui
repoussent les victimes tous un génocide
de 800000 personnes a commencé la france
meilleure alliée du rwanda n'a rien fait
pour l'éviter
ils savaient très bien que quelque chose
se prépare est d'ailleurs à la radio rtl
m qui est fort mais qui étaient extrêmes
utiliser ça approche on va tuer les
tutsis on va tous et les exterminer
c'était un français yvonne et pierre
vivent désormais dans les collines du
sud de la france loin des mille collines
du rwanda
si la mission d'information
parlementaire réunie pour la première
fois ce matin le leur demande ils sont
prêts à témoigner des choses qu'ils ont
vu là bas du comportement des troupes
françaises de ces soldats français
qu'ils disent avoir vu entraîner des
miliciens devenu plus tard des
meurtriers ils sont décidés à apporter
leur contribution au nom des disparus
au nom de la vérité le président
américain bill clinton poursuit sa
tournée en afrique aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de son passage en ouganda
il a voulu exprimer les regrets de
l'amérique d'avoir eu recours à l'esc là
bas jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle pour
développer notamment son agriculture
dans le sud du pays nous avons eu tort à
ce sujet a déclaré le président des
états unis
en algérie les sept membres du commando
islamiste qui ont été condamnés à mort
pour l'assassinât de l'évêque d'oran
monseigneur claverie font l'objet d'une
demande de clémence de la part des
évêques d'algérie qui veulent exclure
toute idée de vengeance et demande au
contraire le pardon pour ses assassins
des astrophysiciens français du cea le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique sont
partis au chili pour étudier un des plus
grands mystères de l'univers
la masse noire invisible du ciel et dont
l'étude est pourtant essentiel pour
connaître notre avenir jean claude
annick vincent mer au nord du chili
la partie la plus aride de la cordillère
des andes à 2400 mètres d'altitude
les quatorze télescope de l'observatoire
européen de la cia nathalie palanque et
française astrophysicien au cea
elle travaille sur le programme eros
l'étude et la recherche
les objets ce sombre dans le ciel
exemple une étoile qui se transforme en
trop noir un mystère qui conditionne
l'expansion et donc la survie de notre
univers est une énigme fondamentales
dont la clé se trouve dans ce ciel
exceptionnel ce site a été choisi pour
ces conditions climatiques c'est-à-dire
milieu environnant très sec sans vapeur
d'eau sans nuages sans pluie donc des
conditions absolument extraordinaire
pour pouvoir faire des observations
astronomiques
la lune est déjà levé pour les
astronomes
c'est une journée de travail qui
commence ce soir le télescope sera
pointé sur les nuages de magellan de
galaxies visible seulement dans
l'hémisphère sud jusqu'au petit matin
nathalie va faire équipe avec cécile une
autre française les puissante caméra du
télescope ont scruté le ciel du chili un
sou de 150 mille années lumière dans
l'espace
et parmi ce million des toiles du petit
nuage de magellan peut-être le
scintillement inhabituelle une seule
étoile comme ici qui permettra de
détecter un trou noir 95% de travail de
fourmi 5% de résultats et
deux passions et les constatations alors
pour 6 5% là ça vaut la peine
exaltation par exemple en assistant en
direct à l'explosion d'une étoile
transformer en supernova la semaine
dernière justement découvert une
supernova qui a explosé dans une des
galaxies que l'on observait ce produit
environ une fois par siècle et par
galaxie presque sept heures du matin la
nuit des astronomes de la cia s'achève
quand le soleil commence à se lever
grâce à internet les affirmations des
heures précédentes sont transmises en
france au centre du cea à saclay pour
nathalie et cécile il est l'heure
d'aller se coucher après un dernier
regard vers le ciel
le guide du routard le michelin des
budgets plutôt réduit fête son 25e
anniversaire le guide du routard ce
n'est pas simplement des combines pour
aller à katmandou en équateur à moindre
frais c'est un état d'esprit et pas
seulement pour les voyages au long cours
donc on peut être routard en france et
même en banlieue parisienne en portage
eric lemasson pierre emmanuel ludot
l'amour
lamarre c'est un état d'esprit que les
plus de 20 ans sont rares à connaître
encore pierre josse lui est un vrai de
vrai il fut il est il sera toujours un
routard autant dire un dinosaure ces
temps ci c'est à ivry sur seine banlieue
rouge de paris qu'il va drouille muni de
ses galons de rédacteur en chef du guide
du routard ultra club au plus tôt que le
lait car le voyage dans son esprit
commence au coin de la rue suit un
journaliste artisans de chez l'ébéniste
des guides de voyage ou à mon savoir
faire cesser mon instrument de travail
ainsi que le carnet et 2 kg et ma
matière c'est les gens que j'ai
rencontrés c'est les architectures qui
pour mémoire le routard tentait naguère
de démontrer que tous les chemins de
l'auto-stop mène à katmandou né en
change prochains titres de la collection
la banlieue l'enquêteur routard se fait
fort d'y dénicher des perles entre les
falaises grise des hlm pour la première
fois en 72 ibiliz et 70 un architecte a
tenté de rompre avec les les bars avec
les blockhaus avec les structures
verticales et ces dernières si texture
humaine beaucoup plus horizontale
originale en rupture complète avec ce
qui se faisait à l'époque
en rupture avec l'époque en accord avec
celle qui commençait voilà précisément
le succès du guide du routard avril 73,2
étudiant en commerce et en pattes d'eph
lance un guide du genre un peu classique
comment gagner des sous pour voyager
quelle tenue revêtir pour l'auto stop et
autres conseils d'amis l'esprit de mai
68 triomphe pas encore les ventes
25 ans plus tard les cheveux du routard
on raccourcit ceux du cofondateur
philippe blot again sont devenus gris et
personne ne croise plus authentique
routard depuis longtemps paradoxe les
ventes ont explosé numéro un des guides
de voyage 1 million 800 mille routard
ont été vendues l'an passé question le
routard est il toujours le routard
c'est vrai que nous avons un petit peu
évolué parce que les goûts ont évolué si
autrefois on bouffait du kilomètre on
partait en inde en auto stop dans des
conditions incroyables pendant plusieurs
mois maintenant je sens que la clientèle
les lecteurs jeunes du guide du routard
cherche un peu plus de deux que de
confort un peu plus de sécurité
mais ce qui n'a pas changé c'est
l'intimité entre le lecteur et son guide
compagnons de voyage 600 lettres
arrivent ici chaque semaine le lecteur m
a précisé contredire s'indigner le petit
village qui n'était pas envahi quand on
y est allé il est devenu très très
touristique cité balnéaire champignons
ces plages pas terrible c'est vrai que
les lecteurs nous sont d'une grande aide
parce que même s'ils sont pas eux qui
refont guide puisque les enfants ne
prend quand même parcimonie ce sont
quand même eux aussi qu'ils nous donnent
la température devenir adulte c'était
pour le routard apprendre à doser entre
l'esprit baba cool des débuts et les
exigences de l'époque le journaliste
artisans lui continue sa route il
découvre les murs à pêches qui firent
jadis la gloire de montreuil sous bois
avec toujours le même entrain 73 pays
en 25 ans et il n'est ni blasé ni
changer il a pour toujours
l'esprit routard
il rentrait chez lui
la chance lui sourit à nouveau bernard
lama rappelé en équipe de france de
football pour le match de demain soir
contre la russie à moscou le gardien de
but qui évolue désormais en angleterre
vous savez doit sa sélection de dernière
minute à la blessure du titulaire fabien
barthez blessé à la cuisse
l'amérique a décerné ses oscars du
cinéma les pronostics ont été confirmés
le film titanic qui a remporté 11 oscars
égalant le record de ben-hur c'était en
1960 stefano faita nec les au
raz-de-marée annoncé a eu lieu onze
oscars titanic égale le record de
ben-hur en 59 avec james cameron le
réalisateur
on ne sait jamais où finit la
mégalomanie je suis le roi du monde et
où commence le cinéma
julien droit
meilleur film de l'année meilleure
réalisation meilleure musique meilleurs
effets spéciaux mais pas de ce quart
pour les acteurs
mais ça peut couler toute seule chose
qui écris moi c'est l'instant précieux
ces quelques secondes ce silence une
minute de silence pour les victimes du
naufrage avant le retour des stars jack
nicholson est sacré meilleur acteur et
event sa partenaire meilleure actrice
ensemble pour le meilleur et pour le
pire
c'était très serré ce soir je ne savais
vraiment pas qu'il l'emporterait j'ai
frôlé la crise de nerfs tout étonné kim
basinger oscar pour un second rôle dans
et les country dance hall on attendait
gloria stuart la vieille dame de titanic
je suis sur un nuage et c'est moins cher
que le prozac
robin williams autre star autres second
rôle récompensé pour son apparition dans
will hunting de matt damon et ben
affleck 25 et 27 ans nouveau chouchou de
riom voile avant de nous quitter le
rappel des principales titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi présidence de
région l'udf qui compte 5 président élu
grâce aux rondes aux voix du front
national est réuni
la direction nous l'a confirmé tout à
l'heure françois léotard demande leur
demande de démissionner sinon ils seront
exclus c'est ce que nous a confirmé
françois d'état président de l'udps et
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
je vous rappelle qu'il existe maintenant
une météo juste avant ce journal tous
les jours aux alentours de 19 heures 56
20h50 le hussard sur le toit le
magnifique magnifique film de jean paul
rappeneau avec en trop juliette binoche
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités marie
pierre farkas faudra elie wiesel prix
nobel de la paix voilà je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur la prochaine
à demain poncet
ce soir mes dames